oh
it's okay i'm an intruder too
[Music]
the return of dr mysterio
this was the second holiday special that
we got between series nine
and ten and it seems to be a very
polarizing one
i i i'll be up front i enjoy this story
i have fun with it um a lot of people
don't and i
i suspect that some of the ambivalence
about it at the time it came out had to
do with
well how long it had been since there
was going to be more doctor who and how
long we were gonna have to wait until
more
after this you know we didn't get a
proper series the year this came out we
just had this special
and i think that just put a lot of undue
pressure on the story that wasn't
built to hold up to that kind of
pressure
so i i'm not gonna say that if you
didn't like it you just had
on you know fair expectations but i do
expect that at least at the time that it
aired there was a little bit of that in
the air
i've always kind of liked this and i
think in a lot of way that speaks to
the differences in what sort of things
you're
prepared to make allowances for for
certain tones matching certain type of
stories because
i've said repeatedly across this rewatch
that
i tend to not care all that much for
the tone of a lot of the christmas
specials the
lighter sillier goofier more
almost deliberately child aimed sort of
humor
and themes and uh elements
and i've had it pointed out by plenty of
my uh subscribers and commenters that
it's taking
sort of the vibe of that you get from
the
christmas panto which is a uk tradition
that doesn't exist in the us
so for me something being a christmas
thing
is it doesn't carry with it a license to
be
silly if the thing is not normally that
silly
the reason i'm pointing this out is for
me
i will make allowances for silly
super heroics because while i may not
have
grown up with christmas pantos i um
i did grow up with superheroes
and yes granted i was actually buying
comics in the 90s and reading the dark
and gritty stuff i've got a
little long box in the closet that's got
a ton of
like spawn and pit and ridiculous stuff
but like i also grew up on the
1966 batman uh
well the movie based off that tv show
and like the
the fleischer superman cartoons like i
have an appreciation
and a nostalgia for corny
silly super hero stories that
gives me a higher tolerance level for
that and
i find them endearing in a way that it's
silly cause it's christmas
doesn't do anything for me so because
this one has a superhero theme
i'm actually way more forgiving about it
despite the fact that overall tonally
it is not that different from episodes
that i have complained about the tone on
so this is me admitting to that
dissonance and trying to point as to why
i'm okay with it here and not elsewhere
and that also this is not a measure for
anybody other than me
to use these are my hang-ups and my
preferences so there you go
but i really do have fun with this one
the actual christmas element is a light
touch which
at this point i kind of prefer i feel
like they
the show did episodes earlier that
really
leaned in on the christmas element i
think
christmas carol probably being the one
that did it the hardest
and since then it's not worth trying to
top the christmas element of that so
a token acknowledgement and then moving
on from there cool i think that's uh
that's a pretty good way to to go about
it
so it really only factors into the uh
early
bit of the story and i'm
i'm loving capaldi in this because this
is him finding his happy medium that i
then get to enjoy
for pretty much his entire run on series
10. because i've noted before
there's a trajectory to capaldi's
character and it's not a straight line
it is a trajectory because he starts out
very grumpy and very reticent to sort of
get in close with people and over
time in series nine i'd actually say he
goes through something like a midlife
crisis and he kind of
overdoes it finding the fun and to the
point that
you know there are some not great
consequences to that and then
in series 10 he kind of finds the middle
ground
where he has the sense of fun but he
is not pushing it so hard with the
sunglasses and the guitar
and all these things which is not to say
that i dislike the sunglasses in the
guitar i actually did enjoy those but i
do appreciate sort of
dialing it was a little much for a lot
of people sort of dialing back a little
bit and like finding
the the right wavelength for the doctor
i really feel like this
is the first time i'm seeing my favorite
stretch with my favorite doctor
in terms of his characterization of the
way he behaves
so that's that's a big thing for me
so the this is also our um
i would actually call it a
reintroduction to nardole
he's not quite where i want him to be
yet um come series 10 i actually like
nardole a lot but this is kind of a
middle step
between husband's river song where i
honestly didn't like him because he
spent most of his time
you know making weird noises whining or
screaming
and series 10 where he was a proper
fleshed out character and actually not
nearly as much about making silly sounds
here he's kind of splitting the
difference between the two he's
better than he was in husbands of river
song at least better to my
tastes but he is still sort of the
vehicle of some of the
more humor you know the the opening
joke being the little boy's room
restroom
joke ah and there are a couple of
extended bits of him
screaming which i really don't and no
like doctor who needs to not cast people
on the basis of them being able to
scream
they they did that with mel in the 80s
and i feel like they did that with matt
lucas initially until they decided to
actually write him a proper character
but we get glimpses of that proper
character at
the tail end when the doctor leaves not
prepared to talk about
river and nardole fills in some of the
blanks
for the other characters who are there
so
let's talk about that the whole thing
with
the ghost and you know the plucky
reporter who basically is lois lane
and this plan to take over the world
before all this
this is classic silly
superhero stuff and i'm here for it
a big part of it that i actually kind of
appreciate and this is kind of odd for
me given that
i didn't read conversations i wasn't
born like my mother
wasn't even born back when a lot of the
stuff was really at its heyday but the
golden age of comics
you know which is like the 30s by a lot
of measures
it takes that vibe by large and it's
borrowing that
feel but along with it it took the
fast quick banter of
film stories of that time and you know
what i
love fast quick fanta i love characters
who are
so quick that this conversation could
not happen at this speed in real life
i don't care because it's awesome and i
love feeling like i'm just barely
keeping up
with these people and i get that
from these characters with with uh both
lucy and grant they're both very quick
and again in a way that like doesn't
make for realistic dialogue no but
realistic dialogue is boring
and uninteresting to listen to if i want
realistic dialogue i will have a
real-life conversation
give me quick and this gives me that and
i enjoy that
and i like that it's not even pretending
to be anything other
than a pastiche of superman that
like with a couple of tweaks making him
a nanny
instead of like her co-worker and you
know
actually giving him a proper mask so it
makes more sense that she doesn't
recognize it but like minor tweaks aside
it's superman he has superman's
mentality he has superman's power set
that's what it is and it doesn't pretend
to be anything other than that and i
like i think justin chatwin
is a great cassie but i feel bad for him
i feel like in a lot of ways
his career for the last decade or so has
been
paying penance for dragon ball evolution
which was
not his fault like he wasn't good at it
but holy cow
that thing so it's um
it's nice to see him just get to
be charismatic and
hold the screen in the camera which he
can do very well
i also kind of like all the stuff that
goes on the front end when grant is
younger because well first of all i kind
of like that the doctor doesn't
get superheroes like the premises and
the concepts like well
no that's just ridiculous and that given
that he effectively
is a superhero in a way like i kind of
like that that he just
he doesn't get them and i also like he's
got really cute interactions when
with grant when he's when he's a kid
when grant points out that this detector
or whatever it is that the
doctor has built i can't remember
exactly what it is now um
it looks a bit like a christmas tree the
doctor goes do you want to turn the
lights on
can i no it's christmas day what do i do
ah it's like it's just this really cute
sweet moment and also the
it was a pretty believable
misunderstanding with the doctor handing
him a glass of water and then this
little crystal saying take
this you know it is completely
understandable what it was that happened
there
so that's that's nicely done there isn't
much to say
about the villains in this one the the
brains and the jars and i know it's
something it's a little bit of a
callback
because when we had husbands of every
song there's a character who
pulled open his head and pulled out a
thing so i guess it's meant to be a call
back to that except it
honestly i didn't even realize that at
the time that i did because that had
been such a minor throwaway character
in husbands of riversong that i didn't
even register it
back when this aired originally because
also you know a year had passed
so i'm not sure it functions very well
as a callback and as far as a
as an overall thing i mean it's kind of
a neat idea the
brains with eyes the splitting it's it's
a decent aesthetic it's mildly creepy
it's it's just creepy enough that said
the fact that they like
keep things in there is very dumb like i
remember even the first time i watched
it when he
splits his head open and reaches in and
takes out a gun i'm like in
what way is that more efficient than
just having
a gun holster
like you and it's also one of those
things that it takes so long the fact
that the heroes just stand there and
like
while he splits open his head and
reaches in and takes out a gun and like
not even quickly
and they just stand there and oh no
that moment doesn't work at all i think
that's the that's the thing
the split and the like that's fine but
the idea that they store stuff in there
no that's dumb and like dumb to a degree
that actually impacts the story because
like i said i'll give a fair amount of
leeway to this story because of my own
preferences but it's dumb in that it
makes the heroes look done for
for just standing there it also kind of
implies that the brains got away at the
end which is a setup for
nothing that never comes back which i'm
not saying i would have
really liked it too but like
not everything needs that kind of setup
oh the one of the i
i like i like the uh the mr huffle
interview
i like lucy squeezing this thing that's
this really slow
[Music]
thing just to make the person who she's
interviewing uncomfortable she does it
every time she thinks she's being
lied to and i i really love the force
with which she squeezes thing
she's like she makes it seem like she is
causing pain
it's it's ridiculous and i don't think
that works as a tactic
in any sort of actual interview
but i i it's inventive
i enjoy it and i enjoy this and i can't
really
if it's not to your taste i can't turn
you around on this i can't defend it
on much more of a basis than it just
hit notes and concepts that i enjoy
sometimes that's just what happens and
for me it did happen with this
i think it is still at this point my
favorite
of the doctor who holiday specials
and a lot of that just has to do with
appealing to the stuff that i
like and my childhood and my nostalgia
in a way that
most of the other christmas specials
just don't but this one does
and i really enjoy it the return of dr
mysterio
have you seen it would you think about
it you rewatched it lately whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch of stuff to do i'm sure you
know what it is there is a patreon that
i have
that keeps the lights on and helps me
pay my bills keeps this entire thing
up and running and in addition to that
there is of course
merch and social media etc etc check
down in the description
for all of that or don't
i can't tell you what to do end of the
day you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]